this is Bruges in Belgium famous for
chocolate lace and beer and this is the
half moon Rory the Rory on the site for
somewhere around five centuries these
3:30 in the city but modern production
and making enough beer to meet the
export demands of the world make that
difficult the half moon Rory moved their
bottling operation outside the city
years ago about two miles
but brewing stayed here this was the
last brewery in Bruges there has been
new Brewers coming along with new ideas
recently so now we are not the only one
anymore
but we're definitely the oldest one who
are we to change the location of the
third logistics are tricky when your
entire city center is a World Heritage
Site getting ingredients in was tough
enough but having to also bring tanker
trucks through narrow cobbled streets
fill them up with beer and then drive
them out the bottling plant two miles
why well they need a better solution so
they built one the beer gets into the
pipe right from the brewing room which
is here and goes from one time here in
the city centre of Bruges to another
tank on the other side in the bottling
plant the pipelines about this size
that's the outer diameter and inside
that one you have four pipes which are
approximately 8 centimeters diameters
the beer goes through as a rate of about
five to six thousand liters per hour
it's not such a high flow rate that it
isn't a pressure it's relatively slow so
it takes a batch of beer about a small
hour to get to the other side the beer
enters our site here it goes in one of
the big tank the lagering process goes
down for three weeks then the beer has
to be filtered pasteurized we add sugar
and yeast and then everything goes into
the bottle each inside the bottle has to
to the second fermentation and that's
happening in a warm room after the
transport we clean our pipes with
cleaning products in with disinfection
inside of the five then we flush it the
ground
300 litres of water before we veer into
this pipeline game outside the city
centre along Holly why is sure regular
excavators were fine but here some more
creative approaches were needed getting
permission for this project wasn't easy
we were lucky to have some
forward-thinking people in in our city
that agreed with his idea and gave us
the permit
they'd friends-only under public domain
so only under the streets not under
houses or private properties and they
actually drill from a distance so they
make a hole kind of like on every corner
of the street and then they have a kind
of guided drilling whereby they don't
need to open up all the streets in order
to drill for months of construction is
normally project that's welcomed but the
locals of Broome seem to think that this
was something special
the locals initially thought it was a
joke I think people really took to the
idea and actually joked a lot about
tapping off the pipeline and getting
beer in their own home where kitchen it
wouldn't be possible to connect to a
path or even a house along the pipeline
however that's why we invented actually
the crowdfunding that's where the idea
came from so people could crowd fund to
actually get some beer for life which
was the replacement of having a little
gears have in their own house thank you
to everyone at a half moon brewery in
Bruges pull down the description for
more about them